what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it really does look
like Sony is switching things up for the
better there's a lot that they have in
the works right now over at Sony with
their Spider-Man universe although it's
been kind of Rocky so far it looks like
they're about to turn it around in a
really big way if you are a fan of
Andrew Garfield and you're waiting for
Chasm 3 if you are a fan of Tobey
Maguire and you want to see more of him
as well these are things that are
actually on the table over at the Sony
Spider-Man universe and the cool thing
is we could be seeing more than just the
two of them the two other Spider-Man
besides Toby Maguire more than just them
show up in the Sony Spider-Man universe
we could actually be seeing some old
villains from their respective universes
popping up in some upcoming movies and
I'm specifically talking about Madame
Webb and the two characters I am
specifically talking about today are
Venom and Harry Osborne and no I'm not
talking about Tom Hardy's Venom but I am
specifically talking about Topher
Grace's Venom from Spider-Man 3 and
Harry Osborne from The Amazing
Spider-Man franchise we'll be breaking
down these latest rumors and there is a
lot to talk about especially if you
consider the fact that Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield are rumored to have
signed a deal to appear in Avengers
Secret Wars and Kevin feige is working
very closely with Sony to work on their
Sony Spider-Man universe right now and
it looks like Sony could be taking a
page from Marvel's Playbook and be
building a universe kind of like Marvel
Studios did if you have been following
the latest Sony Spider-Man news or if
you've been keeping up with the channel
you probably know that Sony is building
up a huge Universe this universe is
going to of course be focused on
Spider-Man and Spider-Man characters it
is indeed going to be a Multiverse and
the Multiverse is going to truly start
with the movie Madame Webb and for those
of you who may not have kept up with the
latest news Madam Webb is essentially a
cosmic entity who can go through the
Multiverse she can travel to different
universes and right now it's looking
like the villain of Madam Webb is going
to be Ezekiel Sims a character who has
pretty similar powers to Spider-Man in
the comics and in the movie it looks
like he's going to be able to travel the
Multiverse as well and hunt down
different variants of Spider-Man now
with the latest rumors that Topher
Grace's Venom and Dane to Hans Harry
Osborne could show back up specifically
in Madame Webb it makes us kind of
excited about what Sony could be doing
with their future projects obviously
with the Multiverse popping up and being
a major factor of what they're trying to
do the possibilities are pretty much
endless I mean Spider-Man no way home
was a perfect example of what could
happen seeing three amazing different
Spider-Man all on screen at the same
time working together to defeat villains
from other universes as well however
there could be a big problem that comes
with this which we're about to talk
about but first let's address these
rumors and how they could possibly come
to play in Madame Webb so this rumor has
been reported on by a lot a lot of
different websites including fandomware
but I believe the original report is
coming from the account spider
underscore culture and they say take
with a grain of salt Green Goblin from
II and Venom from Spider-Man 3 could
return in Madame Webb now we all know
how good Sony is at keeping secrets none
of us knew that Andrew Garfield or Toby
Maguire were going to be in Spider-Man
no way home
[Laughter]
okay so they may not be that good at it
so this report could entirely be true
and it actually makes sense for a movie
like Madam Webb this movie is apparently
going to show us many different
universes all of which take place inside
of the spider-verse from what we've
heard about the villain so far is that
he's going to be going two different
universes trying to kill Spider-Man
variants to essentially eliminate all of
the Spider-Man across the Multiverse and
we can assume it will kind of be up to
Madame Webb to stop him but while we
explore these other universes this is
where we could see these other
characters that used to be in previous
Sony films I don't think they're going
to be bringing these characters from
other universes into one main Universe
rather I think we're going to explore
other universes and see these characters
once again now keep in mind these
universes have already been brought up
by Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
returning in Spider-Man no way home so
these universes exist and there are
Spider-Man in these universes which
means they could be visited by Madam
Webb I know fans would absolutely love
for this to happen and I'd do think it
is a really good idea if Sony does it
right and you've probably heard me say
that before but it's true they have to
do it right they can't just do it for
fan service however there is a big
difference between just throwing
characters out there for the heck of it
because the studio thinks that it'll
bring people to watch and it'll make
money and actually doing it right within
a good story and I think this is
actually what Sony is doing now they are
listening to the audience they realize
that a lot of people really love
Spider-Man no way home they loved Andrew
and Toby back but they also loved the
story and they realized that they can do
this again if they keep making good
stories bringing these characters in as
a part of the overall great story not
just bringing them back to do it because
if you're a studio you do have to
somewhat at least listen to your
audience because these are the people
going and watching your movies and
buying them you have to pay attention to
what they like and what they don't like
so creating a Multiverse and exploring
other universes and seeing old
characters in old universes is a really
great idea if it fits really well and
the story they are trying to tell and
since Madam Webb is going to explore
different Spider-Man universes it does
fit rather well in the story so if this
happens I do believe it's a very good
call they are also setting up a
possibility for more than just
Spider-Man variants to appear but other
variants to appear on the same screen at
the same time for example it's been said
that Sony is going to be building up to
a spider get in movie this will
essentially be a movie like Avengers
Secret Wars it will involve a bunch of
different Spider-Man variants all from
different universes coming to one main
Universe fighting against a villain or
multiple different villains and this
could be really cool considering the
different types of variants that Sony
has for example if they do bring back
Topher Grace's Venom well that Venom was
kind of evil and that Eddie Brock was
evil however if you look at Tom Hardy's
Venom and his Eddie Brock they're not
really evil they're more of anti-heroes
so if you ever did get the two of them
in the same movie they would actually
actually verse each other so we could
get Venom vs Venom so as you can see
there are a lot of great possibilities
that come with a Multiverse done right
and the great news is is it seems like
Sony seems to be resetting their
Universe whatever plans they had before
with morbius and Michael Keaton's
vulture jumping into that universe that
may still happen and may be able to be
tied into Madame web somehow but it does
kind of seem like they're somewhat
abandoning that a little bit it seems
like they're going to focus on Venom 3
with Tom Hardy and could possibly even
bring in Andrew Garfield Spider-Man for
that and then from there essentially
build on the story arc that Madam Webb
is going to introduce to us this will
bring multiple different universes but
should also bring a main Spider-Man to
the MCU it is confirmed that we are
going to see a pregnant Mary Parker who
is the mother of Peter Parker so she
will be pregnant with Peter Parker could
this be the rebirth of a Spider-Man in
the main Sony universe or could this be
in Another Universe an alternate
universe because again we can expect to
see several different universes in in
Madame web it is a multiversal film so
this could be the rebirth of the Sony
Spider-Man universe leading us to spider
get in this is kind of what Marvel
Studios is doing right now they are
building up a Multiverse to lead up to
Avengers Secret Wars Kevin feige is
working with Sony so they could be doing
something similar but only with
Spider-Man and his variants and what's
really cool is if they do in fact do
spider get in it'll take place after
Secret Wars so we could be getting more
spider men in one film again before
spider get him because like I mentioned
in secret Wars It's been reported that
Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield might
have signed a contract to appear in that
film and since they all came back for
Spider-Man no way home and agreed to do
it and loved doing it and now have seen
how much the fans appreciated them
coming back and how much the fans truly
do love them it makes sense that they
would want to do it again even if the
Cameo is for but a brief moment so as
far as Spider-Man is concerned I think
his future is very bright both in the
Sony universe and in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe hopefully we'll start
to see a bunch of different variants and
in both universes hopefully we'll get
people like Miles Morales spider Gwen
and others inside of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and hopefully we get
those in the Sony Spider-Man universe as
well but let me know your thoughts about
these reports in the comments down below
and the overall direction that Sony
seems to be going and don't forget to
subscribe and like the video to stay up
to date on all of the latest Spider-Man
news as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof